>> Chris: NOW IT IS TIME TO
PLAY WISH YOU WERE HERE, WISH
YOU WERE HERE.
YES E-MAIL AND DIRECT MESSAGING
HAS MADE COMMUNICATING WITH
OTHERS FUN AND CONVENIENT IN THE
DIGITAL AGE, BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL
THOSE ANTIQUATED FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION LIKE SMOKE
SIGNALS, CARRIER PIGEONS AND THE
EVER POPULAR POSTCARD.
FORTUNATELY THE BAD POSTCARDS
TUMBLR ARCHIVES SOME OF THE
WORST OF ALL-TIME. I WILL SHOW
YOU A REAL BAD POSTCARD AND FOR
250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE
ME A LINE YOU WOULD EXPECT TO
SEE WRITTEN ON IT.
OKAY, FIRST UP, THIS SOUTHERN
ABOMINATION.
>> OH!
>> Chris: JASON.
>> FINALLY ATE AT TOBY KEITH'S
RESTAURANT.
THE KU KLUX KLAM CHOWDER WAS TO
DIE FOR.
>> Chris: POINTS. KERRI.
>> WISH YOU WERE HERE. AND
WHITE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE T IS GUN TOTING LAWMAN.
WHERE IS HE GOING TO TAKE YOU TO
JAIL, JASON.
>> DALE SAYS I HAVE A VERY
FORGIVING ANUS.
>> Chris: I WOULD LOVE SO SEE
THAT WRITTEN ON THIS POSTCARD.
KERRI.
>> GUESS WHO BROKE HIS
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAIN!
>> Chris: POINTS. POINTS TO
KERRI.
LAST ONE, THIS CHEESE CITY
TOURIST TRAP.
RANDY.
>> SO I TOLD YOUR MOTHER WHAT DO
YOU SAY WE GO AROUND THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS THING AND PUT SOME
HOLES IN IT.
#SwissFist.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WISCONSIN'S THE ONLY PLACE YOU
CAN GLORY CHEESE.
>> IT IS.